thank you for the introduction
as well as the opportunity to present
chem partners capability regarding
antibody discovery
using b cell cloning approach
and thank you everyone for listening in
on this talk
today i'm going to present cam partners
diesel cloning capability using
berkeley lights beacon platform for
generating unique
and coaching antibodies
we wanted to evaluate the accelerated
discovery
of anti-pdl-1 antibodies by b-cell
cloning method and
traditional hyperdoma method
so we recombinantly expressed selected
antibodies discovered by both methods
and
further characterize these
antibodies for parameters such as
binding
blocking and affinity
so we have several different options
when selecting the antibody discovery
approach to use
there is either phage display hybridoma
or b cell cloning
and there are pros and cons of each of
these methods
particularly for phage display
it can be a shorter duration of four
months
there is flexibility in terms of
types of antigens that you can use
and having sequence information early in
the drop discovery process
the screening format tends to be a cfv
as well as fab but one of the challenges
is that you may need to affinity mature
your lead candidates
but generally there is a large library
required in order to identify really
good binders
for the other two technologies hybridoma
and b-cell cloning
tend to leverage the annual immunization
and the benefits of that are to
have in vivo affinity maturation
so there is really no need for
affinity maturation similar to what
you might encounter in page display
with the hyperdoma particular
the duration can be a bit longer
and the members you wish to evaluate
could be a much lower than b cell
cloning method
because of animal immunization uh both
methods could have challenges
if it's a toxic or highly conserved
targets
generally there has been more success
with challenging targets though
the advantage is that screening format
is ig for both methods
but what we really feel is uh
transformative
with b-cell cloning i mean especially on
a beacon platform is that you are able
to really screen
deeper into a immune repertoire
in addition to possibly skipping
overall affinity maturation process
that great sampling of immune repertoire
really enables accelerated discovery as
well as evaluating what the sequences
are
uh early in the process and what's most
important is being able to move
function forward in the drug discovery
process
so at a chem partner we have berkeley
lights beacon platform in order to
accelerate antibody discovery
so on the left there is the beacon
instrument
and it is able to accommodate up to four
octa select chips
which are shown in the middle of the
slide here
the optoselect chip actually houses a
sub nanoliter chambers called nanopens
and we use controlled
patterns of light to move the single b
cell into the nano pens
and within the chip you can evaluate
tens of thousands of single b cells
you can culture these uh b cells
allowing them to secrete antibodies
and then assay for
target specific binding
as well as function
all directly on the platform
at chem partner we are uniquely
positioned to be able to generate the
reagents needed for an antibody
discovery campaigns
so for our uh proof of concept study
using hybridoma and b cell cloning
method
we generated reagents uh for
immunization such as a human pdl1 ect
we generated recombinant cell lines such
as human pdl one overexpressed on cho k1
uh as well as xenopedial one on chokey
one
we also generated recombinant antibodies
that were then characterized through a
variety of assays
so there is a acid development group
in our
shanghai facility
who developed binding acid
as well as the functional assays
including t cell activation as a
pd-1 pdl-1 blocking assay
mixed lymphocyte reaction acid to
evaluate the functional properties
we compared hyperdoma technology in our
shanghai facility to the diesel cloning
capability at our
south san francisco location
we did vh and vl sequencing by ngs at uh
shanghai facility
and
and also
did further characterization
afterwards
so this is a snapshot of b-cell and body
discovery workflow
uh the immunizations we tend to
outsource or work with client to have
immunizations done
but
we receive the lymphoid tissue such as
bone marrows spleens or lymph nodes from
the immunized animals
and we do the isolations and plasma
pieces enrichment at our
site at south san francisco
we load those b cells on the beacon and
can execute binding
blocking assays or other functional
acids
and then export the b cells that have
the desired binding or blocking activity
once those b cells are exported we
prepare the cdna
bh and vl and send it out for sequencing
and upon sequence analysis we can then
clone
express and purify at our shanghai
facility and do
functional characteristics
characterization of these antibodies
so this is the general overview of any
project to be executed on beacon
platform
it comprises of five different stages
stage one is reagent generation
which takes up to three to four weeks
and it it includes reagent generation
at our location in shanghai or even a
client can provide us the
desired desired reagents
we perform the quality assessment of
these regions
we develop the assay for title analysis
we also screen all the parameters on
beacon
beforehand
we also
optimize the post export workflow if we
are using for example any transgenic
mice such as alloy
stage two is immunization and as i
mentioned before
we
do outsource this process at a local
vendor
we perform a serum tighter analysis
and typically this process can
can be for 30 to 60 days
stage 3 is
beacon experiments where we are
screening
thousands of plasma b cells
on beacon on a
11k chips
which basically allows us to screen
up to 11 000
single b cells on a single day
now we can
screen two to three times more in the
same week if we have
excess of plasma p cells available
we typically culture those excess b
cells
in a prop
in a proprietary
mouse b cell medium
on a stage 4
we typically do the export and post
export workflow of beacon
the export process is a
overnight process and is generally
automated the cdna generation and vhvl
amplification
and sequencing takes up to three to four
weeks the stage 5
where
the production and characterization of
the recombinant antibodies is done
it
it very well depends on the client's
preference
because some clients prefer
to have it done at chem partner where
our shanghai's team would help us out in
in producing the
antibodies as per client's preference
or some client prefer to do that at
their own location
the typical process for us would be
for around four to eight weeks
so really what we find as having the
most value for this platform
is being able to move function forward
in the drug discovery process
so on the beacon chip you are able to
assay for target specific binding as
well as functional properties
within the channel or within the pen
and in the next couple of slides i will
show you some of the examples of assays
that we have developed on beacon at chem
partner
and some of the other assays we are
considering
on this platform include a cytokine
release epitope winning
and cytotoxicity
so besides being able to screen a
thousands of a single b cells while
maintaining diverse repertoire
we feel that the most value for the
platform is in identifying candidates up
front
that have the desired functional
properties
which overall accelerates drastically
recovery process
so here i have shown some of the
in-channel binding assays
where you can see either beads
or cells that express target of your
interest are loaded
into the channels such that a b cell
that is secreting
target specific antibody
will show up as a bloom
with a signal right above the pen of
that specific b cell
so you can potentially assay for
in in a format such as this is antigen
specificity as well as cross
cross-reactive binding
we have been able to look in a multiplex
format
a cross-reactive binding to mouse human
and xenoproteins all at once
so on this slide i have shown some of
the in pen binding assays
on left side you can see
either beads or cells that express
target of your interest
are loaded into the nanopin
along with the single b cell
the binding signal will be detected
surrounding the cell or bead
if that b cell is secreting anybody
specific to the target
for the blocking activity
we imported detection antibody here uh
conjugated to alexa fluorophore 488
so that we could detect the presence of
secreted antibody
then we introduced soluble lichen
fluorescently
labeled uh here shown as pe
so we can see signal in both channel
such as that the secreted antibody
is specific to the target but does not
outcompete ligand
but in the image above you can see an
example of blocking antibody
where you see signal coral correlating
to the antibody binding to the target
but there is limited signal in pe
channel
suggesting that antibody prevents the
binding of
ligand to the target on either cell or
bead
now on the right side you can see that
we have labeled two cell lines
expressing
target of your interest with two
different dyes here green
or violet
then introduce detection antibody
fluorescently labeled here
with pe
the binding signal observed with two
channels pe and fitzy
suggest that the antibody is specific to
the cell line which was labeled green
and not violet
so you can potentially assay four in in
a format such as this
is antigen specificity
to one target with counter screening
against another
as well as cross-reactive binding
here i have shown an example of in pen
reporter gene assay which we have
developed in early 2020
on left side you can see a reporter
cells were imported along with single b
cell
we incubated them on chip for about 20
hours
to detect the signal of the gene
induction
if the b cell secretes specific antibody
which thereby activates a pathway here
we tested an f kappa b pathway
which induces the signal associated with
gfp reporter gene
then we will notice reporter cells
turning green on beacon the beacon
instrument allowed us to capture image
every
hour during this incubation process
so on top you can see images shown with
interval of 4 hours
and we were able to detect the onset of
signal as early as 4 hours
which thereby increases its intensity
till 16 hours and then saturates
on the bottom you can see the video
with increase in the signal
throughout those 20 hours
so for this proof of concept project
with berkeley lights we actually wanted
to compare the output of b cell cloning
campaign on beacon platform
compared to standard hybridoma approach
we had binding and functional assays as
well as affinity and diversity assays
done in order to
compare the properties
of the antibodies coming from both
methods
we use identical regions for
immunizations by ip
and similar assays were used during
screening process
we ended up harvesting spleen
and bone marrow from the immunized
animals for both hybridoma as well as b
cell cloning
for hybridoma we use
sjl
as well as pulp c strain of mice
and the detection methods are a little
bit different between beacon
versus screening for hyperdoma
supernatant
so i will go into next couple of slides
describing that
our target here is of course pdl1
and we were able to use benchmark
antibodies to evaluate our antibodies
coming from these two campaigns
compared to benchmarks
so comparing the b cell cloning workflow
to the standard hybridoma workflow
the amount of time that it takes to get
the sequences
not including the time needed for the
animal immunizations
is shown here
for b-cell cloning
once we have the purified b-cells
we were able to load on beacon and
export the b-cells that have the desired
properties
and then initiate the sequencing within
two to four weeks total
and comparing that to hybridoma
technology
the duration is quite a bit different
the process involves fusion
followed by primary and secondary
screenings
in this case we did elisa binding as
well as blocking assays
we did look at a human and
sino-cross-reactive binding during the
primary and secondary screening stages
we had to select 40 to 50 high priority
clones for
production and purification
of course we got the characterization
information but at that point we are
actually using
all of the characterization data to
select top candidates
before doing the sequencing
and by not having that sequencing
information
it can actually create challenges later
in the event that top candidates are
not as diverse in terms of sequence
as perhaps you would have liked it
if we would have known that the the
sequences
earlier
this slide shows the format of the
elizabeth blocking assay
that was used for hybridoma supernatant
screening
and so in a classical format of a
blocking assay we coated with human ptl1
ecdfc
and came in with anti-pdl1 antibody
from supernatant and detected that
either in the
presence
or
absence of biotinylated pd1
now if there is a complex formation with
biogenerated pd1
that would indicate
that it was a non-blocking antibody
and if the signal completely excluded
the by generated pt one that would
suggest that it was a blocking anybody
so this was an elisa based
quantitative evaluation of blocking
activity
and
we cast a broad net anywhere between
thirty to hundred percent in a battery
uh activity
was how we selected our heads to move
forward to uh sub cloning process during
the
primary screening of hyperdoma
supernatants
so in contrast on beacon platform we
used image based method for selecting
our blockers versus non-blockers
so on left you can see we loaded the
pens with chokey one
cells over expressing human pdl one
protein
along with single plasma b cell and
allowed to secrete antibody
and then import beads that
were coated with human pdl one
so in this format you can look at in
channel beat base binding
as well as in pen
cell-based binding
for the blocking activity we imported a
detection antibody
here uh conjugated to
alexel of flora4568
so that we could detect the presence of
anti-pdl1 antibody bound to the cells
or beads
then introduced soluble lican
pd1
fluorescently labeled here shown as
alexa floral 488
so if we see the signal in both channels
suggest that the secreted antibody is
specific to the human pdl1
but does not out compete soluble like
and pd1
but in the image above
you can see
an example of blocking antibody
where
you see a signal correlating to the
antibody
binding to human pdl1
but there is limited signal in
fitzy channel suggesting that antibody
prevents the
binding of pd1
to pdl1
either on cell
or beat
so this is the comparison of b-cell
cloning versus hyperdoma output
so on top there is the b-cell cloning
results
for either self-paced
or bead-based binders
in total we evaluated around 33 000
single plasma b-cells on the chips
over 200 of them
bound human pdl-1 on choking one cells
and of those 35 of them had
blocking activity and over 500 pound
human ptl1 on beats as well
so on bottom here you can see the
results of primary and secondary
screenings of hyperdoma supernatants
where you can see over 50
bound human pdl1 on cho k1 cells
and similarly on
sinopedial one on choke one cells as
well of those 48 had 48 had
variable degree of blocking activity
so here we identified more number of
blockers from
hybridoma approach
compared to a b-cell cloning approach
however
false positive
is a definite concern
during a hybridoma screening
the results of the blocking
assay is been shown on this slide
as you can see from the table
some of the clones which were considered
as a
blockers during the primary screen
did not maintain the same blocking
activity
when they were purified
so basically during the secondary screen
or once they were purified
the activity was lost
so in general 32
of the clones actually lost this
activity
so even though
we had more number of uh blockers
compared to b cell cloning approach
we can certainly say that this is a low
efficiency screening method
because
these clones actually
did not retain the inhibitory activity
once they were purified and
revalidated
so overall we identified 35 blocking
antibodies
from b-cell cloning approached on beacon
platform
we recovered unique vh and meal
sequences of them
and
we eventually expressed 22 antibodies
after the hot spot analysis
we also purified
a good set of
antibodies from hyperdoma approach as
well
and both the
purified antibodies were later
uh characterized for binding by eliza
and by facts
as well as a blocking
by eliza and the
affinity measurements were
were done
the data was also uh compared against
the
benchmark antibodies listed below
and i will be showing you some of the
data in the uh next couple of slides
so here you can see the uh blocking
essay done by eliza on the purified
antibodies
identified by a b-cell cloning approach
as well as hyperdoma approach
the
assay was done
in order to
understand
or evaluate
the inhibitory activity
of these antibodies by preventing the
interaction
between pdl1 and pd1
and as you can see
19 antibodies which were
identified by a beacon platform
had
equivalent or better
inhibitory activity
compared to
the 11
antibodies which were identified by the
hyperdoma approach
as you can see from the
graphs
they have a
really good blocking
profile
and is very similar to
those of the
benchmark antibodies
so here we have this isofinity plot
to really evaluate what we ended up with
these antibodies from both approaches
compared to benchmark antibodies the
sensograms of a benchmark and top two
clones from beacon platform are
shown on the right side here
as you can see that these and two
antibodies look similar to benchmark
antibody
a very fast on rate and slow
dissociation curve
we actually had uh several antibodies
from b cell cloning campaign
that had a single-digit nanomolar
affinity
or better
so overall we can say that
a beacon platform certainly gave us the
really good output
so here is a summary of the
antibodies that we were able to obtain
from
a b-cell cloning and hybridoma approach
overall as you can see from the
hierarchical crossring tree
that the most of the antibodies were
unique and randy and
distant from the benchmark but i
definitely wanted to point out that the
two antibodies that
had a
uh really good affinity which are
listed in this green box are unique as
well as distant from the
the the four benchmarks that we
tested they are also listed in the red
box
and i also wanted to mention that
we noticed that we had
all the antibodies
from b cell cloning approach had 100
unique sequence
uh unlike the hyperdoma where sometimes
the
dominant clone takes over the other
clones and your diversity
may be lower
compared to the b cell cloning
so this is a slide basically summarizing
the evaluation of the
antibodies obtained from
both campaigns b-cell cloning and
hybridoma
so overall we can say
that there are a number of factors that
needed to be
considered
uh certainly
the time that it takes to to get these
sequences two to four months for beacon
platform in comparison with eight to ten
months in
uh hyperdoma approach
the selection
criteria is extremely important
because uh
in beacon platform we use
a very clear image based
selection
where we look for the negative signal
for the uh
for the soluble liquid in case uh in
here
in the fitzy channel
compared to the hybridoma approach where
still it's it's a
quantitative elisa
but i think the
selection criteria is so much
so much
variable that you end up choosing the
blockers which had the inhibitory
activity with the 30 to 100
which
may end up being
uh more false positives basically
so overall we had around 35
blockers
by beacon platform and over 40 blockers
from hybridoma
but as you can see the false positive
rate for
uh for b-cell cloning is around 20
versus 32
for hyperdoma
and if you are comparing their
functional activity
you can definitely see
the uh the bottom half of the table
where you can see their
their affinity their blocking activity
as well as
their functional activity in the t cell
assay
and overall we can say that we were able
to get really
high quality and thai pdl one
antibodies
by a beacon platform
so at the end what we learn from this
proof of concept
study is that
hyperdoma did give us the
more number of hits or the blockers but
none were more important than the
benchmark antibodies
and affinity did not correlate as well
as well with the potency
also when they were tested in the
functional
assay
fear had the functional activity in an
orthogonal t cell activation assay
while in comparison with the beacon
platform
it uh it obviously accelerated the whole
discovery process but we also got the
chance to have a greater sampling of a
immune repertoire to identify potent
blocking clones and also as explained
earlier
two clones which had this sub nanomolar
affinity
completely correlated with their potency
so here just acknowledging all the folks
who contributed immensely in this proof
of concept study
uh our team in south san francisco our
team in shanghai and also birthday
lights team
who
helped us understand this instrument as
well as answered all our questions and
also helped us to
develop new assays which can be
used in our future projects
so uh thank you everyone for uh for
listening to this talk
and i'm looking forward to your
questions
so basically here trying to answer some
of the questions that you
um have
for example the first questioning what
is the relationsh
between immunization strategy and the
hit rate
so certainly there is a
correlation between the uh route of
immunization that is
uh done
so in our past experience we noticed
that if we do the hawk based
immunization
then we would focus on the lymph nodes
where most of the hits come from
followed by the low number of heads
which come from spleen
and
typical uh duration of the immunization
is around 30
32 days
for the ip based immunization which is
uh
usually for 60 days
we would focus on spleen
or bone marrow most of the heads are
basically
coming from a spleen
okay
the next question is how plasma b cells
are isolated and screened on beacon
so once the immunization is completed
we get the
tissue as explained earlier and then we
basically make a single cell
suspension
from
from those tissues
and then we used a
magnetic commercial magnetic kit from
either from stem cell or miltailing
which basically uh have a cd138 positive
uh selection uh cocktail which basically
enables us to
uh isolate plasma b cells
and these plasma b cells are
then loaded on to tb cells typically we
would expect to get around 300 000 to
500
000
single plus
sorry plasma b cells
from three to four mice
and we would get certainly more from the
spleen though
this is what i was
talking about the lymph nodes but
usually they are more than enough to
screen
these cells two to three times
on beacon because we would screen a
certain
population of these plasma b cells on
day one we will keep the excess uh b
cells in the incubator with the mouse
uh
b cells or the mouse or human b cells
that we have internally developed and
then screen those
uh remaining cells on the subsequent
days
okay the next question is
uh what type of screening acids that
were done on beacon so as uh earlier in
the talk i have already explained you
what type of acids that are done the
most common acids that are requested are
the in channel acids you can do the
binding assay cross reactive assay
multi cloud cross reactive assay
multiplex format
uh you can also do the cell based uh
cell based assay
uh sequentially if you have multiple
uh cell lines to screen against you can
also do
in pen cell binding and
and uh eat based in channel assay uh
combined so there are multiple ways of
of doing the
this assay on beacon
and we have certainly tested a couple of
different configurations that have
worked
on number of projects that we have done
in past
uh we have also done the in pen binding
and blocking acid which is also seem to
be very popular certainly because you
can identify the
uh potential candidates having that
blocking activity early on
and recently our projects also been
focused on these uh reporter assays
where we were able to identify certain
certain clones which basically activates
the pathway and that was basically
uh
seen in in form of gfp signal over
a certain time so those kinds of assays
are also
uh can be done on on beacon platform
okay and the next question is what is
the overall recovery and diversity of
the clones
the overall recovery in our experience
is is typically around 80 percent uh so
we have basically uh
uh basically have let's say about
hundred
uh hits from beacon there is also an
attrition rate
uh from from the identified hit up to
the
getting the sequences of them at certain
stage typically our cdna recovery is
really good as it is around like 95
but at some times you would probably
lose some of the clones during the vh
and vl amplification
stage as well as
as well as the sequencing stage so
typically we in our experience we were
able to recover around 80 percent of the
clones
and uh the the good thing about is the
whatever clones that we were able to
recover had the hundred percent
uh unique pairing between vh and vl
so basically you will you will yes you
will lose 20 percent of your clones but
the remaining ones ones were all 100
percent uh unique in terms of the
sequences
okay and that's all the
questions
thank you everyone